you've got here uh how bitcoin isn't
immune to the collapse
of the everything bubble but will
benefit long-term even if there is
short-term volatility
right like so we're seeing an exodus
from cash
and other assets and things like gold
into bitcoin because people are starting
to recognize that
it's scarce properties are super
important in a world where digital
money makes a lot of sense everything's
being disrupted by
the internet and digital money just a
native internet
money just makes a lot of sense and also
a store of value
gold is a 10 12 trillion dollar market
cap bitcoins 500 billion so it just has
a lot of upside if bitcoin can compete
with gold which it probably
will and probably will surpass in my
lifetime i expect bitcoin to become a
global reserve asset like
in the tens or even 100 trillion dollar
of market cap
so as the wall street and institutions
and super high net worth individuals and
entrepreneurs and
all this whole this new class of
investors are coming into bitcoin
there's they're recognizing the
properties that make it special of
censorship resistance and
decentralization and the scarcity
aspects of it so what that's doing
is it's it's it's replacing the old
class of like
people like me who were who were just
interested in the technology and wanted
to see it become a hedge against central
banks and stuff like that
with a new class of investors who are
already exposed to the existing markets
so if if your listeners probably have
stocks and probably have some gold and
some real estate
and now they want to get some bitcoin
well they're the new class of investors
that are coming into the market right
so if the if if the big event happens
where we hit we head into a big market
crash and the market melts down
i mean your listeners are probably going
to try to sell all the [ __ ] they have to
to get some cash because they want some
liquidity
and it doesn't mean that bitcoin is
immune now just because bitcoin acts as
a hedge against
um these these sort of events doesn't
mean it's immune to people selling their
bitcoin
because they're gonna want cash until
cash starts to hyperinflate in a way
that we can see it in our daily lives
people are going to still naturally
gravitate to want to go to cash in
emergencies
so in the short term if there is a stock
market crash
bitcoin's going to drop probably 50
percent just like it did in march 2020
2020. like everything like oil went
negative
like think things are things are not um
uncorrelated at the macro level
to that extent like bitcoin is not going
to protect you against a black swan
event
but in the long term bitcoin is going to
protect you against the deflation and
the devaluation
sorry the inflation of money the money
supply which devalues your savings
so if you're thinking about bitcoin as a
long-term bet
you'll be fine just buy some more on the
dip but people are
when people panic they sell everything
and they fly they fly to cash
yeah that's cool you know when they sell
it all then bitcoins on sale just buy as
much as you can afford right
you